we like to go to tiktok to the lost  souls of tick tock  and uh kind of give them some advice so  let's uh let's go to the first one so  for all my girlies dating men this is  what you're gonna do on your date so the  bell comes i'm you okay  do you need any help with that what are  they going to say yeah you need help  with that in a patriarchy created by men  where men are paid more than women even  though women typically do a better job  in a world where all wars have been  started by men in a society where 90 of  rapes are by men uh no this is you can't  have it both ways okay and by the way  she says that uh  well men they you know they do all the  bad things in society yeah men also uh i  don't know build society and here's the  thing  we do all that we make the hamburgers we  build society  we're willing to do it  and we're also willing to pay the bill  but then you have to do your part of it  which is to drop the whole feminist and  powered stick  take it or leave